Thanks to Skillshare for supporting this episode
of Journey to the Microcosmos.
The first 1,000 people to click the link in
the description can get a 1 month free trial
of Skillshare’s Premium Membership.
Our oceans and lakes are filled with copepods,
a myriad of small crustacean species that
might float as plankton or infect other creatures.
And as they’re living in whatever manner
best suits them, some copepods—like our
friend here—become more than just their
own creature.
They become a surface, a place for someone
else, or something else, to settle down upon.
In the case of this copepod, the residents
that have taken root on its carapace are many,
many ciliates, their single-celled bodies
accumulating into a microscopic bouquet.
And before we get into the specifics of what’s
going on with this meeting of crustacean and
ciliate, I want to ask you a quick question.
Don’t overthink it, just go with your gut instinct:
Who would you rather be in this scenario?
The copepod?
Or the ciliate?
Now I promise you that there’s no right answer
to this question.
It’s just something that’s interesting
to think about whenever we peer into the microcosmos
and see creatures with habits that seem
quite different to our own.
Though we should note that we do have some
things in common with
the microcosmos in this context.
Our skin is covered with its own array of
microbes, an invisible community of bacteria
and fungi and other creatures that affect
the way our bodies interact
with the world around us.
So if you were asked who you’d rather be,
a human or a microbe living on a human, we
would not blame you at all if you stuck with
what’s familiar and instinctively went with
“a human being please.”
But the microbiome on our skin has a different
experience, than say,
these ciliates growing on a rotifer.
For one, they spend their lives in water,
which means they have a completely different
environment shaping their needs and microbial
relationships.
Plus, they are a whole lot smaller than us.
So that’s what we’re going to focus on
today: what happens when one tiny creature
decides to live on another tiny creature.
There’s a name for this kind of relationship:
epibiosis, and it’s not limited to the microcosmos
or to water environments.
It might help to think of it as the flip side
of another relationship we’ve watched play
out in the microcosmos: endosymbiosis, where
one creature decides to live on the inside
of another one, like these algae growing inside
of a hydra.
But the relationships between endosymbionts
and their host can look different depending
on the species.
But in cases like these, it might be the host
providing shelter in the form of their bodies
in exchange for nutrients made by their endosymbiont.
In contrast, epibiosis is when one creature
decides to live on the outside of another one.
And sometimes epibiosis is super obvious,
like it was with the copepod we started out with.
But take a look at this dinamoeba.
This organism was first described by the American
naturalist Joseph Leidy in the 19th century.
And from a distance, it doesn’t seem like
the dinamoeba has much going on.
There’s certainly no ornate, flowery growths
protruding from it.
But when you zoom in, you can see all sorts
of bacteria and archaea arranged on its surface.
In this case, those bacteria and archaea are
epibionts, which is the name that we give to
organisms growing on top of the other organism.
And the dinamoeba is the basibiont, the organism
that the epibionts are growing upon.
And in the microcosmos,
sometimes you are the basibiont,
and other times you are the epibiont.
This leafy ciliate zoothamnium, for example,
can be found growing on copepods, similar
to how we found our ciliates at the beginning
of this video.
But we have also found zoothamnium with euglenoids
growing on them like little green sprinkles
that stay glued to their stalks.
And we’ve even seen strange sights like
these prokaryotes growing on top of a larger
prokaryote, though we’re not sure what species
they are and what they might be getting out
of this nearness to one another.
And given that the diversity in epibionts,
the way they attach themselves to a basibiont
varies a lot as well.
For the smallest microbes, their path towards
their new surface is shaped by the viscous
forces around them, that creates a wall of water
they must break through before they can latch
on to their new home6.
And for unicellular eukaryotes, or even multicellular
ones, the decision to attach itself to another
creature might be just be another part of a longer
life cycle, a shift from a free-swimming self
that ages into something willing to settle
down using an
adhesive molecule to glue them together.
And if you are the basibiont, welcoming these
epibionts might work out well for you.
These new residents might provide you with
some nutrition that you were lacking, supplying
metabolic byproducts that are now very close
in proximity.
These epibionts might even help to hide you
from predators, masking the chemical cues
that give your location away.
But there are trade-offs as well.
For one, you are literally shouldering the
weight of other organisms.
In water, that can make all the difference,
affecting your speed and buoyancy.
And epibionts can even get in the way of important
needs, blocking off the sun or impeding reproductive
organs from their usual functions.
Meanwhile, for the epibiont, there are pros
and cons as well.
Life on another creature means that you’ve
got free transportation wherever your basibiont
chooses to go.
And these surfaces often make for a great
place to grab the remains of whatever your
basibiont is eating.
But life is also unstable on a living surface.
When your basibiont grows or sheds or experiences
some other major life change, you the epibiont
will find the very ground beneath you changing
as well.
There’s this disadvantage inherent to both
epibiont and basibiont life.
In one paper, we found the term they used
was “shared doom,” which is a more poetic
way to say this, “if they get eaten,
you get eaten too.”
And it is a strange consequence to think about,
that this partnership makes its individuals
vulnerable to new threats.
The basibiont now faces the epibiont’s predators,
and vice versa, as if their identities have
co-mingled and blurred together.
And yet they are still two distinct entities:
one lived upon, the other living upon.
So to ask the question again: which would
you rather be?
The epibiont, or the basibiont?
Or maybe there is little difference between
the two, each one shaped by the whims of the other.
Because ultimately, in some way, every organism
on earth, it has to be said, is lived upon
and lives upon just as we are shaped by the
microbes on our skin
and the earth under our feet.
But next week, we’re going to focus on one
case of epibiosis where we think the answer
is perhaps a bit cleaner.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And we’d like to also say thank you to
Skillshare for supporting this video.
You can learn a lot on Skillshare from gardening
to cooking or illustration.
You can even learn how to script, shoot, and
edit your own YouTube videos from one of the
most successful creators on the platform,
Marques Brownlee.
Drawing on a decade of experience, Marques
opens up his process like never before, guiding
you step by step through every stage of content
creation.
From scripting and storyboarding to shooting
and editing, you’ll learn how to create
videos that connect, whether you have one
follower or one hundred thousand.
Skillshare is an online learning community
with thousands of inspiring classes for anyone
who loves learning and wants to explore their
creativity and learn new skills..
With so much to explore and real world projects
to create, Skillshare empowers you to accomplish
real growth.
It’s curated specifically for learning,
meaning there are no ads to distract you,
and they’re always launching new premium
classes, so you can stay focused on leveling
up your skills.
If you’re one of the first 1,000 people
to click the link in the description can get
a 1 month free trial of Skillshare’s Premium
Membership.
And speaking of organisms relying on other
organisms, these are our Patreon Patrons.
They are the people who make it possible to
make the thing that we make.
Thank you so much for all of them being a
part of what we do, it is a pretty small percentage
of the folks who watch who make it possible
for everyone to enjoy everything we do here
at Journey to the Microcosmos.
So if you want to join me in feeling grateful
to them right now, I very much appreciate
it, and if you would like to join them, you
can find us at Patreon.com/JourneyToMicro.
If you wanna see more from our Master of Microscopes,
James Weiss,
you can check out Jam & Germs on Instagram,
and if you wanna see more from us, there is
always a Subscribe button somewhere nearby.